Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是玛丽安。在进入今天的话题之前，我想先告诉大家一个令人兴奋的消息。如果你曾经想过如何创造属于自己的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）发起的“通往经常性收入挑战”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是准心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是来自完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Coming up today, get ready to dive into the roller coaster ride of a third year trainee
这些原则都同样适用。挑战中还有由丽莎本人提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——玛丽安·特伦特（Dr. Marianne Trent）博士一对一的辅导机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree页面“Dr. Marianne Trent”，查看我的社交媒体频道，或者直接给我发私信，我会把所有细节告诉你。好了，让我们开始今天的话题。接下来，准备好深入了解一位三年级临床心理学实习生的心路历程吧。
clinical psychologist's journey. We're about to spill the beans on personal and professional growth. And trust me, it's anything but boring. Whether you're into self discovery, figuring out your own career chaos, or just love a good story of transformation, then this episode is for you. We are peeling back the layers of the ups and downs of a psychology career and exploring how we all go through some pretty significant changes and growth as a result. Hit play, grab a cuppa and let's get real about the messy, beautiful evolution we call life as a psychologist. Hope you find it so useful. Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I'm a
我们将揭秘个人和职业成长背后的故事。相信我，这绝对精彩。无论你是热衷于自我探索、正在理清自己的职业困惑，还是单纯喜欢听励志故事，这一期节目都非常适合你。我们将剥开心理学职业生涯中起起伏伏的层面，探讨我们如何因此经历重大的转变与成长。点击播放，泡上一杯茶，让我们坦诚地聊聊心理学家那既混乱又美好的进化过程。希望这期节目对你有帮助。你好，欢迎收听《准心理学家播客》。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，我是一名
qualified clinical psychologist. So I am joined today by Phil and yeah, I think you're going to find it a really interesting episode. I found it such a privilege to speak with him. So I will catch you on the other side. Just want to welcome Phil Pamperlove to the podcast today. Welcome along, Phil. Hi, Marianne, and thanks for having me. Oh, thanks for saying yes. I reached out to you via LinkedIn because I saw your research. So you are a trainee clinical psychologist and we will come on to what that's been like for you. But you are currently doing your research kind of recruitment drive, I think. Is that fair to say you're still in that cycle currently?
合格的临床心理学家。今天和我一起的是菲尔（Phil），我想你会觉得这一期非常有趣。能与他交谈我感到非常荣幸。那么，我们稍后再见。我想欢迎菲尔·潘珀洛夫（Phil Pamperlove）来到今天的播客。欢迎你，菲尔。你好，玛丽安，谢谢你的邀请。哦，谢谢你答应参加。我是通过领英（LinkedIn）联系你的，因为我看到了你的研究。你现在是一名临床心理学实习生，我们稍后会聊聊你的这段经历。但你目前似乎正在进行研究招募工作，对吗？
Definitely. Yeah, lovely. So could you tell us before we kind of get into all of that, could you tell us a little bit about yourself and how you got into psychology? Yeah, gosh, where do I begin? So basically, I when I was at school, I didn't really know, you know, like many, many children exactly what I wanted to do at the very start. I know some people are like, I want to be a nurse when I grow up. I wasn't quite like that. And also bearing in mind that I grew up in
没错。太好了。那么在深入探讨之前，你能先简单介绍一下自己，以及你是如何进入心理学领域的吗？天哪，从哪儿说起呢？基本上，我在学校的时候，和很多孩子一样，并不完全确定自己想做什么。我知道有些人会说“我长大后想当护士”，我当时并不是那样。而且要考虑到，我是在
Bulgaria, that's where I went to school. So I think that's kind of that cultural difference is important as well. So I remember going through a period in secondary school where I was thinking, I want to be a film director, I want to be a teacher, I want to be this and that. And I didn't fully kind of know really what I wanted to do. Yeah, it was definitely my teenage years where I kind of started thinking about it a bit more fully and thinking, who, you know, who am I? What's important to me? Where do I see myself? I knew that I wanted to work with people and also knew I wanted to help people to kind of help understand themselves. And obviously, again, that's not, you know, that's still such a broad thing to think about. But I remember saying to myself, you know, psychology is such a big field,
保加利亚长大的，我在那里上学。所以我认为这种文化差异也很重要。我记得在中学时期，我曾有一段时间想过要当电影导演、老师，或者其他各种职业。我并没有完全确定自己想做什么。确实是在青少年时期，我才开始更深入地思考：我是谁？什么对我重要？我未来在哪里？我知道我想与人打交道，也想帮助人们更好地了解自己。当然，这仍然是一个非常宽泛的想法。但我记得我对自己说，心理学是一个很大的领域，
you know, and this is where you do work a lot with people not in like a very kind of corporate but in the more sorts of you know empathetic way so I thought to myself you know let me do a psychology degree and see what you know where exactly that's going to take me because psychology in itself is so so vast as a discipline so I did my undergraduate degree between 2011 2014 in the UK during the first year again I kind of found myself in that place where I was like I don't know what I want to do like again I knew I wanted to work with people but didn't know exactly where within psychology to sort of go and I think it was during the second year maybe where I was sort of thinking around the clinical psychology route in particular and thinking to myself you know I remember reading the description of what a clinical
而且在这里，你确实是在与人打交道，不是那种非常商业化的方式，而是更具同理心的方式。所以我对自己说，让我去读个心理学学位，看看它到底会带我走向哪里，因为心理学本身作为一门学科实在是太广博了。我在2011年到2014年间在英国完成了本科学习。在第一年，我再次陷入了迷茫，不知道自己想做什么。我只知道我想与人打交道，但不知道在心理学领域内具体往哪个方向走。我想是在第二年，我开始考虑临床心理学方向，我记得读到关于临床
psychologist does and I was like this is literally me in a nutshell this is quintessentially me because you've got everything in there that I really you know love I'm someone who enjoys kind of doing different things if I do the exact same thing every day in, day out, I know that that's not going to sit well with me. And I really loved all these different facets of psychology in terms of working with clients, but also with teams, working kind of on a broader level in
心理学家工作描述的时候，我心想：这简直就是我，这完全就是我。因为它包含了所有我真正热爱的东西。我是一个喜欢做不同事情的人，如果每天重复做完全一样的事情，我知道我不会适应。我真的很喜欢心理学的这些不同侧面，既能与客户合作，也能与团队合作，还能在更广泛的层面上工作。
So it was working with different models and learning about all of these models all of that was just like yes yes and yes yeah and then at the end of the third year i was thinking to myself do you know what i know i'm not going to get on as soon as i apply after an undergraduate degree but let me see what that's like so i remember like going through the application process to sort of see what that's like i didn't even even submit it. I just sort of wanted to see what kind of questions might come up. And the year after that, I did a master's in foundations of clinical psychology, which was, yeah, it was one year, but within that one year, I feel like a lot of things happened very quickly in a short span of time, because I managed to find a bit like a placement where one day a
所以，能够运用不同的模型并学习所有这些模型，对我来说简直太棒了。在第三年结束时，我心想：我知道本科毕业后直接申请可能进不去，但我想看看流程是怎样的。所以我记得我走了一遍申请流程，甚至都没有提交。我只是想看看会出现什么样的问题。第二年，我攻读了临床心理学基础硕士学位，虽然只有一年，但在那一年里，我觉得很多事情发生得非常快，因为我设法找到了一个实习机会，每周有一天
week I was a voluntary and honorary assistant psychologist in a local service and then the rest of the week was sort of lectures and study time and during that time I was also a voluntary research assistant so I was kind of involved in clinical stuff and research stuff and then doing my studies alongside and again I thought to myself, this is exactly where I want to be heading. And yeah, after I did my master's, I was really lucky to kind of get a paid position within that service where I was on placements. And I was also working part-time as a support worker
我作为一名志愿荣誉助理心理学家在当地服务机构工作，其余时间则是听课和学习。在那期间，我还担任了志愿研究助理，所以我参与了临床和研究工作，同时还要兼顾学业。我再次对自己说，这就是我想要前进的方向。硕士毕业后，我非常幸运地在实习的那个服务机构获得了一个带薪职位。同时，我还兼职担任支持工作者，
with services with autism and or intellectual disabilities. And I was kind of juggling the two. And then later on, I got another part-time assistant psychologist post and then they kind of juggling the two and then later on I got a another part-time assistant psychologist post and then they kind of complemented each other and I was split two and a half and two and a half days and again I was really looking back I think like I was really lucky to kind of land both of these knowing how much of a gold dust sort of thing they are now but they were two very different services two very different teams and I really learned a lot from them and I do miss you know the people I work I remember you know every colleague
服务于自闭症和/或智障人士。我当时在两者之间周旋。后来，我又得到了另一份兼职助理心理学家的工作，它们相辅相成，我每周各分出两天半的时间。回想起来，我真的很幸运能同时获得这两份工作，因为我知道现在这些岗位有多么难得。那是两个非常不同的服务机构，两个非常不同的团队，我从中学到了很多。我真的很怀念我共事过的人，我记得我共事过的每一位同事
and every patient I've worked with very very well and then I remember applying for the doctorate probably four years I'm trying to remember how many years it's been and you know I definitely had moments when I was thinking to myself gosh is it worth it you know this is really draining this is a really hard process and then I would go you know when I was sort of when I had no's basically for one or two or three years or whatever and I was like hmm you know let me re-evaluate you know where I wanted to be I knew this is where I wanted to be heading so reviewed my whole application I completely changed my sort of personal statements in there yeah and then I managed to get a couple of
和每一位患者。后来我申请了博士学位，大概是四年前吧，我记不清具体几年了。我肯定有过怀疑自己的时刻，心想：天哪，这值得吗？这真的很耗费精力，这是一个非常艰难的过程。当我连续一、二、三年被拒绝时，我会重新评估自己想要去的地方。我知道这就是我想要前进的方向，所以我彻底修改了我的申请，重写了个人陈述。后来，我终于获得了几次
interviews and even though I wasn't successful after those interviews that I was like yes I'm on the right track with this you know something's different and they were really good learning experience in themselves and then lo and behold in 2021 I managed to to get an interview at a university I really really wanted and I was yeah I was so so chuffed with myself my family and friends again they were like you really really deserve this and it was definitely a very memorable moment for me that phone call that I got so that was a big waffle there Marianne it wasn't a waffle it was wonderful I could listen to you speak for hours I think Phil I'll just zip my mouth you're like really really interesting to listen to and you know I'm always struck as I'm
面试机会。尽管面试后没有成功，但我感觉自己走在正确的轨道上，有些事情变得不同了。这些面试本身就是很好的学习经历。终于，在2021年，我成功获得了我梦寐以求的一所大学的面试机会，我当时真的太高兴了。我的家人和朋友都说我真的应得的。那通电话对我来说是一个非常难忘的时刻。我刚才说得太多了，玛丽安。不，你说的很棒，我可以听你讲几个小时。菲尔，我闭嘴就是了，你讲的真的非常有趣。而且，我总是被
as I'm also struck by my own story as well of just this perseverance and this determination and I was listening to you speak and I was thinking gosh moving off to a whole new country like where you don't know anyone that's such a big deal and then I thought oh yeah you you did do that too mine was Wales but it was still three and a half hours away you know it's it's a big thing we do you know yours was obviously a whole different culture it's not just England to Wales but we do move around a lot for our passions don't we did you always know that you would want to come to UK and do your professional qualification in the UK would that have been an option to stay in Bulgaria or was that just not what you wanted
我自己的故事所触动，那种坚持和决心。听你说话时，我在想，搬到一个完全陌生的国家，不认识任何人，这真是件大事。然后我想到，哦，你也做到了。我当时是搬到威尔士，虽然只有三个半小时的路程，但这依然是一件大事。你的情况显然涉及完全不同的文化，不仅仅是英格兰到威尔士的距离。但为了我们的热情，我们确实会经常搬迁，不是吗？你一直都知道你想来英国并在这里获得专业资格吗？留在保加利亚是一个选择吗，还是说那根本不是你想要的？
yeah good question and I think it's a very complex and nuanced question because yes I did I did have the the option to you know to to go to Bulgaria and stay there and complete my studies there but I just didn't really feel that that was where I really wanted to sort of thrive and even now like nothing's stopping me you know after I finished my studies to go to Bulgaria and practice there if I wanted to but I just I feel like yeah there's something about the cultural mentality as well where you know at that time when I was applying for university I had friends who were already in the UK and saying really positive things about it and I just yeah I remember being going through a period in secondary school where I was like really interested
这是一个很好的问题，也是一个非常复杂且微妙的问题。是的，我确实可以选择留在保加利亚完成学业，但我并不觉得那是我想大展拳脚的地方。即使是现在，在我完成学业后，如果我想去保加利亚执业，也没有什么能阻止我。但我感觉，那时的文化心态有些不同。在我申请大学时，我有一些朋友已经在英国了，他们反馈非常积极。我记得在中学时期，我曾有一段时间对
in the UK and the British mentality. And I was like, yeah, I could see myself sort of in there. I felt like, yeah, in Bulgaria, certain things are kind of moving a bit slower than the West. And I think that's understandable considering what some of the values and beliefs in there are. So, for example, I'm the oldest of my siblings and being the only male for my siblings I've kind of reflected on that as well what that's meant in terms of having those expectations on me to sort of perform well to know a lot of stuff to kind of lead the way to be that Pathfinder you know like in the snow where you sort of you've got some really thick snow and
英国和英国人的心态非常感兴趣。我心想，我能看到自己在那里的样子。我觉得在保加利亚，某些事情的发展比西方慢一些。考虑到那里的价值观和信仰，这是可以理解的。例如，我是兄弟姐妹中的老大，也是唯一的男性，我反思过这意味着什么，意味着我有责任表现出色，了解很多事情，引领方向，成为那个“开路者”。就像在厚厚的雪地里，
you sort of wondering where to go and you see that someone's already gone through that snow I kind of felt like I've been the person who's done that but yeah as you said it wasn't easy you know moving in itself for anyone whether it's from Wales or Bulgaria or wherever I was 18 at the time when I first started my undergrad and there were so many things I had to get you know to get used to, things I wouldn't even think about, like how to set up a bank account or a contract for your phone in another country.
你不知道该往哪里走，但你看到有人已经走过了那片雪地。我感觉自己就是那个开路的人。但正如你所说，这并不容易。搬迁本身对任何人来说都是挑战，无论是从威尔士还是保加利亚。我开始本科学习时才18岁，有很多事情我必须去适应，比如如何在另一个国家开设银行账户或办理手机合同。
They became actually really big things because now I'm the one responsible for doing this. I'm creating this independence, but it's not an easy step to take. So going back to your question yes I did have the option for that but I think I wasn't sort of ready for that I don't think it felt kind of right and the thing is that I've got a lot of family and friends in Bulgaria who I do visit at least once a year and it's it's kind of difficult because yeah I can't sort of they don't live
这些实际上变成了非常大的事情，因为现在我是那个负责处理这些事的人。我正在建立这种独立性，但这并不是一个容易的步骤。回到你的问题，是的，我确实有那个选择，但我认为我当时还没准备好，感觉不太对。而且，我在保加利亚有很多家人和朋友，我每年至少回去探望一次。这有点困难，因为他们并不住在
around the corner and I can't go and visit them as often as I'd like to. But I do feel sort of sometimes sad for the people who are still in Bulgaria who have to deal with lots of kind of political turmoil. And, you know, it's one of the poorest EU countries as well. So it often gets portrayed that way. You hear lots of narratives about Bulgaria that way. And I want to show another side to Bulgaria as well so I've often reflected on that on my course as well what it means for me to be someone who's got dual nationalities a Bulgarian and a British person. Yeah absolutely and when we look at the diversity of your cohort this year like the one that you're in how is that faring in terms of gender in terms of
街角，我无法像我希望的那样经常去看望他们。但我有时会为那些仍留在保加利亚、不得不应对各种政治动荡的人感到难过。而且，它是欧盟最贫穷的国家之一，所以它经常被那样描述。你听到的关于保加利亚的叙述大多如此。我想展示保加利亚的另一面，所以我在课程中也经常反思，作为一个拥有保加利亚和英国双重国籍的人，对我来说意味着什么。绝对是这样。当我们看你今年这一届学生的多元化程度时，
background in terms of diversity how many are on your cohort and what's that looking for like for you at the moment yeah so I'm in my final final year I'm in my third year now on my course and I think yeah compared to other cohorts and maybe other courses as well, I think we are a fairly diverse cohort. Again, I think overall within the whole country, there's still that kind of the, you know, there's not as much diversity as we want to, but I think we are kind of getting there. So for example, we are at the moment we're 28.
在性别、背景和多元化方面，你们这一届有多少人？目前情况如何？是的，我现在是最后一年，也就是三年级。我觉得与其他届别甚至其他课程相比，我们这一届还是相当多元化的。当然，在全国范围内，多元化程度可能还没达到我们想要的水平，但我觉得我们正在进步。例如，我们目前有28人。
We did start with a few more people. We had a few mums on our cohort who've given birth. So we have six males, including myself, out of 28. So again, that's, you can see what the gender ratio is there, but it's still better than like one or two or none, none at all and I think for me that's quite important being a male sort of I've actually thought about that what is it for male trainees not just where I am but in other courses as well to be in such an environment and to be with predominantly sort of female cohorts it's yeah it's I'm not sure how voiced or unvoiced it has been, but I've definitely sort of thought about that. Yeah. My cohort was really, really small. Mine was 15.
我们刚开始时人数稍微多一点。我们这一届有几位妈妈生了孩子。我们有6名男性，包括我在内，总共28人。所以你可以看到性别比例，但这仍然比只有一两个甚至一个都没有要好。对我来说，作为一名男性，这很重要。我确实思考过，对于男性实习生来说，不仅是在我这里，在其他课程中，身处这样的环境中，身处以女性为主的群体中，这是一种什么样的体验。我不太确定这种感受被表达得有多充分，但我确实思考过这个问题。是的。我那一届非常小，只有15人。
And of those, there was three men. But I loved the male opinion, you know, and just the male dynamic as well that stopped it being a group of 15 women. I really valued that. And when you kind of got to do role play with the the men versus the women young women whatever we were whatever people identify as um I just really valued it yeah I think there's so much to learn from each other regardless of our background regardless of our gender regardless of our culture like I just love how you come together as a cohort and you know like when we're learning about group you know that forming storming norming performing I love
其中有三名男性。但我很喜欢男性的观点，以及那种男性动态，这让它不再仅仅是一群15个女人的聚会。我非常看重这一点。当你和男性与女性进行角色扮演时，无论人们如何认同自己，我都非常珍惜。是的，我认为无论背景、性别或文化如何，我们都能从彼此身上学到很多。我喜欢大家作为一个群体聚在一起的感觉，比如当我们学习群体动力学中的“形成、震荡、规范、执行”阶段时，我喜欢
I love being part of that but I also love hearing other people's stories about how that develops and hopefully you want to still see some of them or maybe even all of them by the time you graduate you know that's the hope that actually it's been it's been a enriching nourishing experience rather than one where you just like I can't wait to not see you again ever hopefully not yeah I'm just thinking to myself what it would have been like for me to be in a cohort of 15 people. Because, yeah, obviously, with recent years, there's been a lot more funding for places. And I'm thinking the group dynamics could change as a result as well. So, yeah, now, as you're saying that, I'm sort of thinking, I wonder what it would have been like if it was the same amount of men, like six, but in a group of 15.
成为其中的一部分，也喜欢听别人讲述这些阶段是如何发展的。希望当你毕业时，你还能见到他们中的一些人，甚至所有人。这就是希望所在，希望这是一种丰富而滋养的经历，而不是那种让你觉得“我再也不想见到你们了”的经历。希望不会那样。我正在想，如果我身处一个15人的群体中会是什么样子。因为近年来，课程名额的资助多了很多。我在想，群体动力学可能会因此而改变。所以，现在听你这么说，我在想，如果人数还是6名男性，但在一个15人的群体中，
Would that have sort of changed things I find it you know at the time one of my friends was in a cohort of 40 whilst I was in 15 because of course there have been bigger universities I loved it it meant that we all had like a common room that we hung out in and there was just enough room for us all to sit on these super comfy sofas and squash up together and we all tended to spend all of our break times not necessarily all of the lunch times because sometimes you go out into town but we all tended to spend all of our break times and probably most of our lunch times together as a group and it was really really nice for my purpose but I can speak for myself you know I loved it you know and we'd on a Friday after after our personal development group we'd tend to all as a standing
情况会改变吗？我记得当时我的一位朋友在40人的班级里，而我在15人的班级里。因为有些大学规模更大，我当时很喜欢那种感觉，这意味着我们都有一个休息室可以待，沙发足够大，我们可以挤在一起。我们倾向于把所有的休息时间都花在一起，不一定是午餐时间，因为有时会去镇上，但我们倾向于把所有的休息时间和大部分午餐时间作为一个群体度过。这对我来说真的非常好。我可以代表我自己说，我非常喜欢。在周五的个人发展小组结束后，我们通常会有一个固定的
date all go to the pub when we finished um whether or not people drinking and then or driving or you know whatever we'd go and just kind of finish off the week spending time as a 15. And if one of us couldn't make it one day, it was a bit like, oh, no. It was really nice. Whereas I know if it had been any bigger than that, that would have made it tricky because you need a bigger room or you split up or you get like small clusters. And even within that group, there were obviously people that I was closer to than others. But I really liked it being that size but I guess it's just you you you learn what you experience don't you and you that becomes your norm so you know it's yeah it's different strokes for different folks but of course probably a smaller
约定，去酒吧聚会，不管大家是否喝酒，或者是否开车。我们只是结束这一周，以15人的形式度过时光。如果那天有人来不了，大家会觉得“哦，不”。这真的很好。而我知道，如果人数超过这个规模，情况就会变得棘手，因为你需要更大的房间，或者大家会分散开来，形成小团体。即使在那15人中，显然也有我更亲近的人。但我真的很喜欢那种规模。我想你只是在学习你所经历的，那成为了你的常态。所以，每个人都有不同的偏好，但当然，规模较小的
course maybe appealed to me yeah yeah there's just so much to kind of think about yeah and I think it's kind of inevitable the bigger the group becomes, kind of the more likely it is to have these sort of smaller pockets of people. Yeah, and I think cohesion is a really important thing because you kind of feel like you're in this together. I remember one of our very first days when I started training, we were told, you know, up until this point, you've been competing to get here.
课程可能更吸引我。是的，确实有很多值得思考的地方。我认为随着群体规模的扩大，出现小团体的可能性是不可避免的。是的，我认为凝聚力非常重要，因为你会觉得大家是在一起的。我记得刚开始培训的第一天，有人告诉我们：“到目前为止，你们一直在竞争来到这里。”
Now you're not competing with each other. You're working with each other. So it kind of made us feel, or at least made me feel, a bit less stressed about the whole thing, thinking, yes, I've made it. Let me, you know, form connections with these people because, you know, who knows where we're going to be when we all qualify. Absolutely. Absolutely. And there's a couple of things cropping up to me as you as you spoke there like the the image of you know during the pandemic there was that we're all in this together oh yeah it's like a really choppy sea but some people were in speed boats and some were in like little kind of leaking sieves and you know even within a cohort you might have that you're physically in the same place expected to do
“现在你们不再是竞争对手，而是合作伙伴。”这让我们，或者至少让我，对整个事情感到压力小了一些。心想：是的，我做到了。让我与这些人建立联系吧，因为谁知道我们毕业后会去哪里呢？绝对是这样。绝对是。当你说话时，有几件事浮现在我脑海中。比如疫情期间那句“我们同舟共济”，哦，是的，就像在波涛汹涌的大海上，有些人坐在快艇里，有些人坐在漏水的筛子里。即使在同一个群体中，你可能也会有这种感觉：你们身处同一个地方，被要求做
the same job but you might well have very different resources and kind of differences in terms of your kind of diversity and the barriers and the oppression and you know your your kind of privilege and you know there's absolutely that within within there but I remember I don't know if you had anything like this maybe not maybe your ego is more robust than mine but looking out on my on my first day and like I'd always been like the psychologist in my friends you know oh ask Marianne or you know it's about mental health like you know ask Marianne whatever um and I really liked that you know so I'm not married to a psychologist and I don't know if I could be like I like being you know the psychologist and then looking out like all these 14 other people and thinking oh there's nothing special about me like I found that almost a little bit tricky to begin
同样的工作，但你们可能拥有非常不同的资源，在多元化、障碍、压迫以及特权方面也存在差异。我记得，我不知道你是否有过类似的经历，也许你的自我意识比我更强。但我第一天往外看时，我一直都是朋友中的“心理学家”，比如“问玛丽安”或者“关于心理健康，问玛丽安”之类的。我真的很喜欢那样。我没有嫁给心理学家，我不知道我是否能做到，我喜欢成为那个“心理学家”。然后看着其他14个人，心想：我没什么特别的。我发现这在开始时
with you know who am I if I am not like if I'm not the psychologist which sounds really narcissistic doesn't it but it was yeah like just being able to bring myself and help myself develop as a trainee clinical psychology alongside these people was almost part of the journey for me as well I think. No I think it's almost like an existential point that you reach in your adulthood where you're like thinking what sets me like apart like who's Phil basically what does who does Phil want to become and even as I've been going through the different placements and now I'm in my final placement for example I've kind of realized which therapy models are more aligned with or what kind of realized which therapy models are more aligned
几乎有点棘手。如果我不是那个“心理学家”，我是谁？这听起来很自恋，不是吗？但作为一名临床心理学实习生，能够带着自我并帮助自己与这些人一起成长，对我来说也是旅程的一部分。不，我认为这几乎是你成年后会达到的一个存在主义点，你会思考：是什么让我与众不同？菲尔是谁？菲尔想成为什么样的人？即使在我经历不同的实习，比如现在我在最后一次实习中，我也意识到哪些治疗模型更符合
with or what kind of populations I enjoy working with the types of services which is really handy when it comes to applying for jobs when you can kind of you know not apply for every single job you've seen but sort of really think about where you would be happy to work and yeah that's just an example of like something I've been thinking about throughout the whole three years you discover more about yourself about what you what you like what you don't like for example one of my values is that I really value being part of a team so seeing people face to face is important to me so I can't imagine myself working in a service where everything is online for example and I also really value connecting long-term connections with people
我的理念，或者我喜欢与哪些人群合作，喜欢什么样的服务类型。这在申请工作时非常方便，你可以不用申请你看到的每一份工作，而是真正思考你在哪里会工作得开心。是的，这只是我在过去三年里一直在思考的一个例子。你会发现更多关于自己的事情，关于你喜欢什么、不喜欢什么。例如，我的价值观之一是我非常看重团队合作，所以面对面见到人对我来说很重要。因此，我无法想象自己在所有工作都在线上的服务机构工作。我也非常看重与人建立长期的联系，
including with clients so you know i would struggle to sort of be in a setting where i'm only seeing a client for like a one-off sort of thing and then you know off you go so i've kind of been reflecting on that as well what does that mean for me why how come you know I've got these sorts of values? So we can go really deep here. But yeah, it's just, I like having these sort of self-reflective moments because you do start thinking, I'm a psychologist and all these other people are psychologists, but each one of us is bringing something different. That's the beauty of it, isn't it?
包括与客户的联系。所以，如果是在那种只看一次客户就结束的环境中，我会感到很吃力。所以我一直在反思这一点：这对意味着什么？为什么我有这些价值观？我们可以深入探讨。但总的来说，我喜欢这些自我反思的时刻，因为你确实会开始思考：我是心理学家，其他人也是心理学家，但我们每个人都带来了不同的东西。这就是它的美妙之处，不是吗？
All of us are individual in that sense. Isn't it just? And that's what I love about clinical placements as well is you get the chance to enter someone else's world for six months you get to try everything on you know and you get to think which bits do I like which bits don't I like which will I keep you know which will I leave here and then never never ever return to again and sometimes you know you get that opportunity that people are like oh well we've got maybe a qualified band seven job coming up we'd love it if you consider coming back which is just like and then you're like well do I want
从这个意义上说，我们每个人都是独立的个体。难道不是吗？这就是我喜欢临床实习的原因，你有机会在六个月的时间里进入别人的世界，你可以尝试一切，你可以思考：我喜欢哪些部分？我不喜欢哪些部分？我会保留哪些？我会把哪些留在这里，再也不碰了？有时，你会得到机会，比如他们说：“我们有一个合格的七级岗位空缺，如果你考虑回来，我们会很高兴。”这简直太棒了，然后你会想：我想要
that and you know it's really really nice it's part yeah like you say it's part of training that you kind of get to figure that stuff out but when I qualified actually it was in a very different economic climate which maybe I hope we're not heading towards again because of the increased importance and highlighting about how important mental health is whereas in 2011 when I qualified they sort of decided to save money by axing places for mental health training which has probably contributed to some of the mental health training, which has probably contributed to some of the mental health crises we see, not just from psychology, but they did it across different disciplines as well. Even there was some dalliances with mental health nurse funding, wasn't there?
那个吗？这真的很棒。这是培训的一部分，你能够弄清楚这些事情。但我获得资格时，经济环境非常不同。我希望我们不要再回到那种状态，因为现在人们越来越重视心理健康的重要性。而在2011年我获得资格时，他们决定通过削减心理健康培训名额来省钱，这可能导致了我们现在看到的一些心理健康危机，不仅是在心理学领域，在其他学科也是如此。甚至还有一些关于心理健康护士资助的折腾，不是吗？
They made it that you had to use, it was no longer bursary. They were trying to save money everywhere. So when it came to us applying for jobs, we absolutely had the things that we would consider, this is a bit of me, but we were literally having to apply for everything. And I don't know how my career would have unfolded had I not had that. Because actually, my first qualified job was a 27 mile trip each way you know up the m6 like it was not my first choice and you know I wouldn't necessarily have considered myself a CAMHS clinician but found myself working in a team that just was so good they won awards for safety that it really helped me develop incredible foundations for qualified work they were compassionate they were kind they were lovely I did so much work with kind of diverse families and client groups and you know using interpreters and it was just what I needed but I didn't know I needed it you know so yeah I ended up working
他们规定不再提供助学金。他们试图在各处省钱。所以当我们申请工作时，我们确实有考虑过“这适合我吗”，但我们实际上不得不申请一切。我不知道如果我没有经历过那些，我的职业生涯会如何展开。因为事实上，我的第一份合格工作需要单程27英里的通勤，沿着M6高速公路。那不是我的首选，我也不一定认为自己会成为一名儿童与青少年心理健康服务（CAMHS）临床医生，但我发现自己在一个非常优秀的团队中工作，他们因安全而获奖，这确实帮助我为合格后的工作打下了不可思议的基础。他们富有同情心，善良，可爱。我与各种各样的家庭和客户群体进行了大量工作，使用了翻译，这正是我所需要的，但我当时并不知道我需要它。所以，是的，我最终在那里
there for almost four years as well but where I would have done you know I would not probably nobody would necessarily choose to do that commute because it was probably up to an hour and a half each way I was worse off when I qualified because I then had to pay council tax and I obviously got no travel funding so I was worse off as a qualified than I was as a band six trainee but I wouldn't swap it because it made me the clinician I am today and I really like really like the clinician I am and the stuff I do so that is a complete other aside but yeah like I hope you have an experience where you're delighted with your first qualified role, even though it might be one that on paper looks already a bit more like a bit of you than mine did. Yeah. Oh, thank you, Marianne. And so kind of heartwarming to hear about your first job,
工作了近四年。如果不是因为工作，我可能永远不会选择那样的通勤，因为单程可能需要一个半小时。我获得资格后反而更穷了，因为我必须支付市政税，而且显然没有交通补贴。所以作为一名合格的心理学家，我比作为六级实习生时更拮据。但我不会交换，因为它造就了今天的我，我真的很喜欢现在的自己以及我所做的工作。这完全是题外话，但我希望你能有一次对第一份合格工作感到满意的经历，即使它在纸面上看起来比我的更适合你。是的。哦，谢谢你，玛丽安。听到你关于第一份工作的故事，真的很暖心，
because I think it'd be quite scary for third years, especially thinking, oh, gosh, like I need to actually start applying for jobs and go to a job interview yeah and you sort of finding that you really loved that that job and the people we were with you learn so much from it and I think that's probably where the placements have been really important for me for me personally on our course I feel like I've learned so much from them and I'm not sure how it was on your course but with us we sort of do two adult placements in the first year both around five six months long and then two five six months placements in the second year one with children
因为我觉得这对三年级学生来说可能很可怕，尤其是想到“天哪，我需要开始申请工作并去面试了”。是的，你发现你真的很喜欢那份工作，你从共事的人身上学到了很多。我认为这就是实习对我个人而言非常重要的原因。在我们的课程中，我觉得我从中学到了很多。我不确定你们的课程是怎么安排的，但我们第一年进行两次成人实习，每次大约五到六个月。然后在第二年进行两次五到六个月的实习，一次是与儿童
and young people the other one with people with intellectual disabilities and in the final year you do one longer placement around 10 months-ish long and you can kind of select your top three choices for which way you sort of want to be so the final decision isn't yours but you've got a lot more control and i managed to get my first choice for my third year and i was so over the moon and i've said to my partner like I didn't for a second like regret making that choice because I really feel like I'm learning so much I'm kind of heading in the direction I want to be heading it's not just trainee Phil but also future qualified hopefully Dr Phil by the end of the year so um yeah I think placements are a really big part where you
和年轻人合作，另一次是与智障人士合作。在最后一年，你会进行一次更长的实习，大约10个月左右。你可以选择你最想去的三个方向，所以最终决定权不在你，但你有更多的控制权。我成功获得了第三年实习的首选，我当时欣喜若狂。我告诉我的伴侣，我一秒钟都没有后悔做出那个选择，因为我真的觉得我学到了很多。我正朝着我想要的方向前进，不仅是实习生菲尔，也希望在年底成为未来的合格心理学家菲尔博士。所以，是的，我认为实习是一个非常重要的部分，你可以
can start learning a lot I've dealt with a lot of things in my placements that I wouldn't have even dreamed of doing when I was an assistant psychologist absolutely and you do just end up having to walk because you find yourself to be there and you know I felt quite emotional as you spoke then like I felt I had the feels like it made me feel like I might have a little bit of a cry like what a privilege you know to to be able to have that level of personal and professional growth and get paid for it you know and I know if you're a counselling trainee you're listening to this thinking I don't get paid and I have to pay and there's such an inequity and I wish that could be changed but you know speaking as a qualified clin psych who got paid to train it you know not every day was easy of course it wasn't but just incredible and I still think I've got the best job
开始学到很多东西。我在实习中处理过很多事情，这些是我在做助理心理学家时做梦都想不到的。绝对是这样。你最终不得不去走那条路，因为你发现自己就在那里。你说话时，我感到非常激动，就像我有了那种感觉，让我觉得可能会有点想哭。这是一种多么大的荣幸，能够拥有那种程度的个人和职业成长，还能因此获得报酬。我知道如果你是一名咨询实习生，听到这里会想：“我没有报酬，我还得付钱，这太不公平了。”我希望这种情况能改变。但作为一名获得报酬培训的合格临床心理学家，我知道并非每一天都容易，当然不是。但这一切真是不可思议，我仍然认为我拥有世界上最好的工作。
in the world like I love it I love it yeah same and you just kind of feel when it's right that you sort of like it's hard to verbalize it but you definitely at the end of the day when you come back and like yes it might have been a tough day but there's something about this that I really really love yeah absolutely is there anything else on this topic around kind of what we learn along the journey that that we haven't said or that you think might be useful that comes to you for that kind of podcast topic title yeah and i guess i'm kind of addressing this to anyone who might be watching this not necessarily trainees qualified you know could be aspiring at whatever stage you are really pause and think about who you
我热爱它，我热爱它。是的，我也是。当你觉得一切都对的时候，你很难用语言表达，但当你一天结束回来时，你会觉得：是的，这可能是一个艰难的一天，但其中有些东西我真的非常热爱。是的，绝对是。关于我们在旅途中学到的东西，还有什么我们没提到，或者你认为可能对听众有用的吗？对于那个播客主题标题，你有什么想法？是的，我想对任何可能正在观看的人说，不一定是实习生或合格的心理学家，可能是任何阶段的准心理学家。真的停下来思考一下你是谁，
are because i remember one kind of teaching that we had is where the lecturer said to us you know imagine an animal you know pick an animal that you want to represent you as a or where you would like to see yourself as a clinical psychologist it was something along those lines and i remember i thought really really long for that and in the end i chose a chameleon and so each one of us kind of went we went around and we sort of each one of us spoke about why they chose that animal. And I said, well, I chose the chameleon because I feel like, in a sense, I want to be someone who is flexible and adapts well to different environments and, you know, different needs. But at the same time, at the very core, I'm still the same person. So I might change sort of the colors, but I'm still there.
因为我记得我们有一次教学，讲师对我们说：“想象一种动物，选一种你认为能代表你作为临床心理学家的动物，或者你想成为什么样的心理学家。”大概是类似的意思。我记得我为此思考了很久，最后我选择了变色龙。我们每个人轮流发言，讲述为什么选择那种动物。我说，我选择变色龙是因为我觉得，在某种意义上，我想成为一个灵活、能很好地适应不同环境和不同需求的人。但同时，在核心层面，我仍然是同一个人。所以我可能会改变颜色，但我依然是我。
The feel is still there. So I kind of want to incorporate that malleability and flexibility, but still stay true to what's important to me. And my partner drew a chameleon and gave it to me as a birthday gift later on. And I still have that. So every time I kind of see it, it sort of reminds me, yes, this chameleon is me. And I know why. Like, I understand why.
那种感觉依然存在。所以我希望结合这种可塑性和灵活性，但仍然忠于对我重要的事情。我的伴侣画了一只变色龙，后来作为生日礼物送给了我。我至今还留着它。所以每次我看到它，它都会提醒我：是的，这只变色龙就是我。我知道原因，我明白为什么。
So really think about who you are and how other people would see you. I think that's such a nice reframe on a chameleon. Because for me, sometimes the term chameleon is almost lobbied about as a bit of an insult. Like, but I think you're right. Like, it's about survival, isn't it? It's about, you know, being a part of something and helping it. I don't know, helping what needs to happen, happen. But in a way that isn't putting all your own stuff and your own agenda onto what the process is I don't think I'm
所以，真的要思考你是谁，以及别人会如何看待你。我觉得这是一个对变色龙非常好的重新定义。因为对我来说，有时“变色龙”这个词几乎被当作一种侮辱。但我认为你是对的，这关乎生存，不是吗？这关乎成为某件事的一部分并提供帮助。我不知道，帮助需要发生的事情发生。但这种方式并不是把你自己的东西和议程强加到过程中。我不认为我是
explaining this very well but you know I get what you mean yeah it's not it's not an insult is it it's it's a real skill to be able to do that but of course to to remain like you said to still remain the same underneath but just to be able to it's an amazing survival strategy isn't it like it's amazing as a you know it makes me think about harry potter and his invisibility cloak like what would you get up to if you had one of those like yeah you know what can you do if you can just be yourself but know how to help others around you maximise everything that they're doing, you know? Yeah, and I totally get what you mean when you first say,
解释得非常好，但我明白你的意思。是的，这并不是一种侮辱，对吧？能够做到这一点确实是一种真正的技能。但当然，正如你所说，在内心深处保持自我，同时又能做到这一点，这是一种了不起的生存策略，不是吗？这让我想起了哈利·波特和他的隐形斗篷。如果你有那样一件斗篷，你会做些什么呢？如果你能保持自我，同时又知道如何帮助周围的人最大限度地发挥他们的潜力，你能做些什么呢？是的，我完全明白你最初说的话。
yeah, I wouldn't think about that. Because when I first thought about it, I was like, oh, but then people might think I'm like being a phony or like hypocrite or something and not really, you know, lying just to kind of please them or something. But I was like, no no I don't see it personally that way um the important thing is that bit about the core the core of you is always the same about you because if I'm always the same and like if I you know don't adapt to different
是的，我不会那样想。因为当我第一次想到这一点时，我在想，哦，但人们可能会认为我是在装模作样，或者像个伪君子之类的，并不是真的，你知道，只是为了取悦他们而撒谎。但我当时想，不，不，我个人并不那样看。重要的是关于核心的那一点，你的核心始终如一。因为如果我总是保持不变，如果我，你知道，不适应不同的
environments you know I'm not going to as you said yeah survive but also thrive I think that's the other important thing you know thrive in an environment where I feel happy and passionate about what I'm doing so that's that's kind of how I personally see it but yeah every time I see that picture I'm like yes it just warms my heart I come from a slightly earlier era in life where we actually used to write each other letters and put stamps on them um before emails dawned and one of my friends um used to write like a little quote or a little like pause for thought nugget on the back of every envelope because he didn't want the postman to be bored that's generally what genuinely why he did it and it reminded me of a little little communication because postman
环境，你知道，正如你所说，我不仅无法生存，也无法茁壮成长。我认为这是另一件重要的事情，你知道，在一个让我感到快乐并对所做之事充满激情的环境中茁壮成长。所以我个人是这样看的。但是的，每次看到那张照片，我都觉得心里暖暖的。我来自一个稍微早一点的时代，那时我们真的会互相写信并贴上邮票，在电子邮件出现之前。我的一个朋友曾经在每个信封的背面写上一句小名言或一段引人深思的话，因为他不想让邮递员感到无聊。这确实是他这样做的真正原因，这让我想起了一点点交流，因为邮递员
must read postcards and he thought this isn't a postcard it's a letter and on the back of one of them it said if you've always done what you've always done then you'd always get what you've always got and that is you know that's that's in essence what that is isn't it I have loved our chat today like I'm so excited for just for you to, to become qualified for you to stand there in your graduation robes. And for me in terms of change, I think I noticed it most. I didn't go to my master's graduation because I think they forgot to tell me about it. Yeah. They sent me a certificate in the post like six months later where I said, well, where is it?
必须阅读明信片，而他认为这不是明信片，这是一封信。在其中一封信的背面写着：如果你总是做你一直做的事情，那么你就会总是得到你一直得到的东西。这本质上就是那个意思，不是吗？我今天很喜欢我们的谈话，我非常期待你获得资格，期待你站在那里穿着毕业袍的样子。对于我来说，关于改变，我想我注意到了这一点。我没有参加我的硕士毕业典礼，因为我想他们忘了告诉我。是的，他们六个月后把证书寄给了我，我说，好吧，毕业典礼在哪里？
They didn't tell me. So I only went to my undergrad and my doctorate graduations. So I only went to my undergraduate and my postgraduate doctoral graduations. In my undergraduation, I felt a bit embarrassed. I felt a bit silly, felt silly in my robes. I felt a bit like a phony. I didn't feel like a psychologist because I guess what I know is that I wasn't one. And I was just a bit embarrassed. I loved being with my family. I loved being with my friends. I loved going out for dinner afterwards with our extended family, but I didn't necessarily feel proud whereas my doctorate graduation I honestly felt so very proud of
他们没告诉我。所以我只参加了本科和博士的毕业典礼。所以我只参加了我的本科和研究生博士毕业典礼。在本科毕业时，我感到有点尴尬。我觉得自己有点傻，穿着毕业袍感觉很傻。我感觉自己有点像个冒牌货。我不觉得自己像个心理学家，因为我想我知道我当时还不是。我只是有点尴尬。我喜欢和家人在一起，喜欢和朋友在一起，喜欢之后和大家庭一起出去吃晚餐，但我并不一定感到自豪。而我的博士毕业典礼，我真的感到非常自豪，
everything I'd achieved of wearing my little you know soft floppy cap of being there with all of these incredible people who I called friends and colleagues and I was so pleased and proud for them as well I had this moment of standing I did Coventry and Warwick uni and they take it in turns for the graduation one year will be in the Coventry Cathedral one year will be in the Warwick in the in their theatre there and we had the Coventry graduation and it was just like standing queuing up by these you know amazing stained glass waiting to go and get my handshake from the dean whatever it was with my parents watching and you know my who is now my husband was in a lecture theater with his parents watching elsewhere and just I just felt so incredibly proud. And that is safe to feel about yourself, but also really lovely.
为我所取得的一切成就，为戴着我那顶柔软的软帽，为能和所有这些我称之为朋友和同事的了不起的人在一起。我也为他们感到高兴和自豪。我有过这样一刻，我是在考文垂大学和华威大学读的，他们轮流举办毕业典礼，一年在考文垂大教堂，一年在华威的剧院里。我们参加了考文垂的毕业典礼，就像站在这些令人惊叹的彩色玻璃旁排队，等着从院长那里握手，无论是什么，我的父母在看着，而我现在丈夫当时在另一个演讲厅里和他的父母一起看着，我只是感到无比自豪。对自己有这种感觉是安全的，但也真的很美好。
And I hope that you have that similar pride when it comes to be your time as well, Phil. Thank you, Marianne. Yes, so fingers crossed that my graduation will be next year. I think they do it this summer after so there's quite a big kind of gap but hopefully a proud Phil proud Dr Phil could be standing there and I think we should be proud at any point in time even you know at the undergraduate that's that's massive you know that's a very big step in anyone's life yeah I guess that evidence is just how much I changed from the
我希望当你到时候，菲尔，你也能有同样的自豪感。谢谢你，玛丽安。是的，希望我的毕业典礼能在明年举行。我想他们会在今年夏天之后举行，所以间隔时间相当长，但希望一个自豪的菲尔，一个自豪的菲尔博士能站在那里。我认为我们在任何时候都应该感到自豪，即使是在本科毕业时，那也是巨大的成就，你知道，那是每个人生命中非常重要的一步。是的，我想这证明了我从
age of 21 to the age of I think I was about 30 you know I'd grown a lot I've done a lot as well had a great time personally and professionally there'd been highs had been lows but genuinely and I guess by the time I did my graduation for doctor I'd already I think that was November I was just about I think to start my qualified role because I actually had some time of unemployed because there was no jobs but yeah I just I just loved it I loved it and yeah in terms of growth it you know there's nothing like it and then of course once you qualify you continue to grow and you absolutely should so yeah just yesterday someone had said they'd been stopped from progressing to 8a because someone had said well you haven't done a specialist core thing you haven't done a bolt-on therapy since
21岁到我想大概30岁时改变了多少。你知道，我成长了很多，也做了很多事情，个人和职业生涯都过得很棒，有高峰也有低谷。但真的，我想当我参加博士毕业典礼时，那已经是十一月了，我当时正要开始我的合格职位，因为我实际上有一段时间失业，因为没有工作。但是的，我只是喜欢它，我喜欢它。而且在成长方面，你知道，没有什么比这更好的了。当然，一旦你获得资格，你就会继续成长，你也绝对应该这样做。所以，就在昨天，有人说他们被阻止晋升到8a级，因为有人说，好吧，你没有做过核心专业的事情，你没有做过附加疗法，自从
qualifying and that wasn't something I'd ever heard of but you know just in case people are listening just try to get some sort of therapeutic skills advancement when you first qualify in the first couple of years but that said you know you can go straight to 8a from qualifying so that's not always necessary but part of the podcast I like to kind of educate people as and when I hear things. So that might be something people might like to consider. So Phil, thank you very much. You are going to be joining us for another episode because I've so enjoyed our chat that we've decided we're going to do what was our original plan as a second follow-up episode because it's just been so lovely to speak to you have you got a last nugget of advice for helping people avoid burnout on their way as aspiring psychologists phil gosh uh i could say so much about that but i'll keep it simple you know yourself best so one thing at a time that's something that has personally helped me a lot both before and during the doctorate just chunking things otherwise you can easily get overwhelmed with how much stuff is
获得资格以来。那是我从未听说过的事情，但你知道，以防有人在听，当你刚获得资格的前几年，尽量获得某种治疗技能的提升。但话虽如此，你知道，你可以从获得资格直接升到8a级，所以这并不总是必要的。但作为播客的一部分，我喜欢在听到事情时教育人们。所以这可能是人们可能想考虑的事情。那么菲尔，非常感谢你。你将加入我们的下一集，因为我非常喜欢我们的谈话，我们决定按照我们最初的计划进行第二次后续节目，因为和你交谈真是太愉快了。你对帮助人们在成为心理学家的道路上避免倦怠有什么最后的建议吗，菲尔？天哪，我可以对此说很多，但我会保持简单。你最了解自己，所以一次做一件事。这对我个人在博士学位之前和期间都有很大帮助，就是把事情拆解开来，否则你很容易被堆积在一起的事情压垮，
happening all together like nope I'm gonna do first this then that then that and obviously life doesn't work that way but I think even just saying it to myself helps a lot so give it your best shot if it doesn't work that's okay just be kind to yourself that's so nice and you know just keep doing it if you think it's a bit of you like it was for you you know what's another year between friends you know if this might end up being your fantastic beautiful joyful career exactly. Thank you very much. I've loved it. I've loved it, Phil. Thank you for sharing your time so warmly with our audience as well. And if people have enjoyed what we've said, then they can look out for our next episode,
所有事情同时发生，就像不，我要先做这个，然后做那个，再做那个。显然生活不是那样运作的，但我认为即使只是对自己说出来也有很大帮助。所以尽你最大的努力，如果不行也没关系，对自己好一点。这太好了，你知道，如果你觉得这适合你，就像它对你一样，只要继续做下去。你知道，朋友之间多一年又算什么呢？如果这最终成为你美妙、美丽、快乐的职业。完全正确。非常感谢。我喜欢它，我喜欢它，菲尔。也感谢你如此热情地与我们的听众分享你的时间。如果人们喜欢我们所说的，那么他们可以期待我们的下一集，
which will be coming probably in the next five or six weeks. What an absolute pleasure it was to speak to Phil. I liked it so much that we are seeing him again for a future episode as well. So stay tuned for that in the next few weeks if you are intrigued to see what it is we're going to be talking about. I would love to know what you think to this episode. Come along and let me know in the Aspiring Psychologist community, which is my free Facebook group. If you like the way I do reflection, if you like the way that it sounds like I can help you to grow and to shape your experiences and to get to where you want to be on the psychology career ladder, please do consider coming along and joining the Aspiring Psychologist community, which you can do from just £30 a month with no
这可能在未来五到六周内播出。与菲尔交谈真是太愉快了。我非常喜欢，所以我们也会在未来的节目中再次见到他。所以，如果你对我们将要讨论的内容感到好奇，请在接下来的几周内保持关注。我很想知道你对这一集的看法。来“有抱负的心理学家”社区告诉我吧，这是我的免费Facebook群组。如果你喜欢我的反思方式，如果你喜欢我听起来能帮助你成长、塑造你的经历并让你在心理学职业阶梯上达到你想要的位置，请考虑加入“有抱负的心理学家”社区，你只需每月30英镑就可以加入，没有
minimum commitment. Please take a moment to rate and review. And if you're watching on YouTube, please do subscribe, like, tell your friends, do all those good things. I hope you'll find some of the videos on screen coming up very shortly on YouTube to be useful for the next choice for you to watch. I will look forward to coming along and seeing you for our next episode of the podcast, whether you listen or whether you watch from 6am on Monday. Take care. Thank you so much for being part of my world. with this podcast that you're sad you'll be on your way to being qualified it's the aspiring psychologist my name's yana and i'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner.
最低承诺。请花点时间评分和评论。如果你在YouTube上观看，请订阅、点赞、告诉你的朋友，做所有这些好事。我希望你会发现屏幕上即将出现在YouTube上的视频对你的下一个选择很有用。我期待着在我们的下一集播客中见到你，无论你是收听还是观看，时间是周一早上6点。保重。非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分。有了这个播客，你离获得资格又近了一步。这是“有抱负的心理学家”，我的名字是亚娜，我是一名心理健康从业者实习生。
I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me, you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的经历非常有趣。有多少种不同的途径可以达到目标让我感到惊讶，成为一名临床心理学家没有完美的途径，这让我充满了信心，不，我没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，这会让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会放下这本书。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。